welcome back to the tutorial
on games that arise from logic and
automata
we're now going to uh take a look at
another motivation
for considering uh games on graphs and
in particular
again party games so it has to do with
complete lattices so what is a complete
lattice it's a
partial order with some set elements
l and we will say that it is a complete
lattice
if for every subset of elements
of the ground set so for every subset
a there is a greatest
lower bound of all the elements in that
subset a
and the least upper bound
in the lattice theoretic jargon the
greatest lower bound is often referred
to as
the meat of the set a
and the least upper bound is referred to
as the join
of that set
now a paradigmatic example of a complete
lattice
is the power set lattice so for any
set u if you take the
set of subsets of that set ordered
by inclusion then that is a complete
lattice
where the meat the greatest lower bound
of
any collection of sets is the
intersection
of this of the sets in that collection
and
uh the least upper bound the join
is the union of those
a classic result of tarsky building on
earlier results of canaster is that
you take a function f from a complete
lattice
to itself and that function is monotone
which means that it is order preserving
then the set of all fixed points of
that function f right so all elements of
l
which are equal to their image
by f that set of fixed points
is a complete lattice itself now let's
parse that
so that in particular implies
that the least fixed point of f exists
and the greatest fixed point of f exists
this follows from the fact that every
complete lattice
has a least element and the greatest
element which are simply the join
and the meat of all elements
in the lattice moreover
tarsky's theorem implies that
those least and greatest fixed points of
a monotone function
can be obtained by a fairly
straightforward
calculation namely in order to
obtain the least fixed points all we
need to do
is to take the join
of all the iterations of
f starting from the bottom element
the smallest element in the
complete lattice and the greatest fixed
point
can be obtained by taking the meat
of all the iterates of
f starting from the top elements in
in the lattice before we define
nested canaster tarsky fixed points let
me clarify
in what sense we can take least and
greatest fixed points
of multivariate functions
on complete lattices so functions of the
form
a finite product of the lattice
of the complete lattice into itself so
firstly
it makes sense to talk about such
functions as being monotone because
a finite product of a complete lattice
can be seen again as a complete lattice
with the pointwise ordering
now if we have a dra
such monotone function
then if we agree on
some say first argument
of that function let's call it x
then what we can do is that we can
define
a d minus 1 re function
which to every d minus 1
tuple of elements in the lattice
yields the least fixed point of the
unary function which
to argument x gives the outcome for
applying f to x
and that d minus 1 tuple
we can do likewise for the greatest
fixed points
admittedly this notation is a bit of a
abuse here because
obviously uh in order for this to make
sense we have to somehow agree on what
the first argument is
the one with respect to which we take a
least fixed point and we can similarly
define
greatest fixed points of such
multivariate
monotone functions from a lattice to
itself
in the analogous way now the fact stated
here is that
such d minus 1 array functions
obtained in the way i've described
when understood as lattice theoretic
functions
from d minus 1 product of l
to l are monotone themselves
this is uh not too hard to prove
and we will use this fact to define the
nested cluster tarsky fixed points
so again assume that we have a
function f from a d wise product of l
into itself and what we are now going to
define
is the meaning of this expression
which takes repeated
least and greatest fixed points with
respect
to the parameters
all the d parameters so it takes the
least fixed point of f with respect to
the first parameter x1 that gives a d
minus one array function
uh in the remaining arguments then it
takes the greatest fixed point and
so here's the definition uh so
f is a dra function monotone function
from a lattice to itself
now we define uh the meaning of this
expression mu
x1 dot f of the
vector of axis as this d minus one array
function
uh which is simply the least fixed point
of the unary function with respect to
argument x1 now once we have this d
minus one array function
uh we can define a d minus two array
function uh
by say taking the greatest fixed point
with respect to variable
parameter x2 so in this way we can
keep applying the least and
greatest fixed point operators uh which
each time we yield monotone functions
and hence
we can meaningfully uh continue applying
uh least and greatest fixed point
operators thanks to
tarski's theorem until we have
applied these fixed point operators
d times and then what we get is a zero
array function so we
we just get an element of the lattice
itself so that's the meaning
of a nested fixed point expression
which starts from a dra function f
and then applies the least and greatest
fixed point operators to successive
parameters of that function and
thus defines an element of the lattice
so here is a construction
which you may find somewhat surprising
because
we suddenly shift from
fixed points in lattices and the tarsky
knaster tarsky theorem to parity games
but here's a construction of a
finite parity game if the original
lattice
was finite and for
simplicity i'm going to in fact
assume that the lattice that we are
working with is a power set uh lattice
turns out that
uh uh the generalization to uh arbitrary
lattices
uh is uh uh maybe
not very enlightening so so we can
see what is really going on already for
the case special case of power set
lattices so imagine that we have a
function a dra function
uh from the power set of
some set of set u into
into itself and we are now
going to define a parity game which will
have two
types of uh positions or
vertices um
the square ones will belong to
player even and the pentagon ones
will belong to player odd
so recall if a vertex or position in a
parity game has an odd number
of sides in this case five then
it belongs to odd and if it has an even
number of sides
then it belongs to even that's our
convention
now the
vertices that belong to even will be
pairs an element of the ground set of
our power set
lattice and a number p
which is a positive integer from the
range between 1 and d now
recall d is the arity of the
monotone function positions that belong
to
odd instead are going to be
um d tuples of
elements of the lattice in this case
the elements of the parasite lattice are
simply
subsets of u so they are d tuples of
sets of subsets of u
what are the moves uh
so maybe let's first talk about the
moves available
to player odd from a d tuple
of sets
player odd will be able to move from
such a tuple
to pair u p
if and only if that
element u of the set capital u
belongs to the p
subsets of u in the tuple
now what moves so far note we haven't
used the function f at all
function f is used to determine which
edges we have
from positions that belong to even to
positions
that belong to odd note that this graph
is bipartite
so every move from an even position
moves
goes to an odd position and vice versa
but it is the moves from the even
positions to the odd positions
that are going to refer to this function
f
this monotone function so we will say
that
there is an edge from u p where p
recall is a positive integer between
1 and d if and only if
u belongs to f
applied to that d
tuple of subsets of u
that this edge is supposed to go to
now note that f is monotone so
the set of edges going out of a pair
up has quite a bit of structure it is
uh in a sense
upwards upwards closed so this completes
the definition
of uh the transition structure of this
game the only thing remaining
is to for it to become a party game
is to determine what the priorities of
the vertices or the positions are
and the
all the odd positions are going to have
priority one which is the smallest
priority
so that's the priority that matters
the least and um all the
positions of even will simply have the
priority of the second
element of that pair up so all those
vertices all those positions will have
priority
uh priority p and here is a remarkable
uh
fact which is
that an element u of the set
of the universe capital u is
belongs to the set defined by this
nested knastatarsky expression that we
have defined
on the previous slide if and only if
even player even has a winning strategy
from any of the positions of the form u
comma some priority in that
nested fixed point game now note that it
doesn't really matter from
which priority in the second component
of this pair we start from
because the set of sets of successes
of positions of the form up
are completely independent of that
component p right they only depend on
uh on on u
so this gives
in a way a game theoretic semantics or
meaning
uh of uh such nested knastatarsky
fixed-point expressions and
i find it quite enlightening because it
transforms a problem which is lattice
theoretic and talks about
fixed points and um perhaps sometimes
quite complex lattices
uh and that translates us to a purely
purely combinatorial
uh problem of determining
winners in parity games
it is worth pointing out here that
the number of distinct priorities that
are used
in this parity game the fixed point game
associated with the uh
nested knastatorsky fixed point
expression
is equal to the number of
alternating fixed point operators
so if you have nesting depth of
least and greatest fixed point operators
then the number of priorities
in the associated games will be equal
to that depth so that highlights the
importance
of the number of priorities as a
parameter
in parity games and as we are going to
see the
complexity of solving parity games the
computational complexity of solving
parity games
will critically rely uh on that
parameter so finally let me
mention why canasta tarsky fixed points
are relevant turns out that this
ability to form fixed points in
complete lattices is a very natural
language
to describe a host of problems in model
checking
abstract interpretation and static
analysis of programs
and in fact throughout 1980s and 1990s
and to this day it is quite common to
simplify conceptually analysis of
various
logics of programs by viewing
the constructs in those logics as
functions defined using fixed points
sometimes nested fixed points
on sets of states of the models
considered
and finally let me now
briefly summarize how games
can be seen as a very natural model for
reactive synthesis
so in fact games have been used in
verification
what is verification well in
verification the task typically is
that we are given a specification
and an implementation that we hope
satisfies that specification so
implementation is a program
specification is a property of that of
behaviors of that program
and uh verification typically
allows us to conclude using some
algorithmic techniques
whether that implementation is correct
that is its behaviors do satisfy
the specification or whether it is
incorrect
now looking at verification problems as
games is often quite enlightening
because rather than just getting
an answer correct or incorrect
if we model a verification problem for
example a model checking problem
as a game which in many contexts is is
very natural
then what we get is more information
because what we get
in each of the cases are winning
strategies either the winning strategy
for one of the players which is
typically called the verifier
or a winning strategy for the opponent
which
some people call the spoiler who wants
to whose aim is to
pinpoint that the implementation is
incorrect that there are
circumstances under which it uh fails to
uh
satisfy the the specification so you can
think of
uh the uh these enriched outputs that
come from game theoretic
uh understanding of the verification
process
as either a proof in the form of a
winning strategy for verifier
proof that the system is indeed correct
or some structured
uh form of a description of what is
wrong
uh with the uh with the program
uh in the form of a winning strategy uh
for spoiler
now the task in uh synthesis is more
ambitious than in verification
because you know people argue that in
verification we may
over invest in producing an
implementation that ends up
turns out being incorrect and there is a
loss of
effort wouldn't it be splendid if
instead we just
um were able to
specify what we want and then an
algorithmic
method to produ to either
say that this specification is
realizable so that means there exists a
program
that meets it as well
as producing an actual implementation
or perhaps the specification is
unreliable unrealizable
and wouldn't it be good then to get some
insights
about why that is so
which perhaps might allow a designer
to adjust the specification so again
it is very natural to view synthesis
problems
as games and we are going to see one
example of how
uh how this this uh takes place
technically
uh but again uh the um
at least in theory the benefit of using
uh game theoretic methods
and using games which are determined is
that in each of the two cases either
realizable
or unrealizable we are hoping to get
winning strategies for either of the two
players in this case in the case of
synthesis they are often called the
controller
the program that wants to
meet the specification or control the
system in such a way that the
specification is is met or a winning
strategy for
the adversarial environment which gives
insights about
uh in what conditions uh what conditions
uh may uh uh prevent from
the program uh being able to satisfy
a specification so um
how can we think about synthesis well
you might
come to this problem from the
viewpoint of programs understood as
data transformers if you take any
textbook and
algorithms then
what are algorithmic problems well they
take inputs and they produce outputs and
they terminate and produce outputs now
typically
for an algorithmic problem to be
interesting it needs to have
infinitely many possible inputs
and that causes such synthesis problems
uh and in fact even verification
problems uh
easily undecidable as as soon as as
problems are come from a slightly
non-trivial
class so that does not prevent people
from trying to do that there is
a well-established line of research
called deductive approach to program
synthesis
where people aim to prove
realizability of desired functions
which typically could take a form of
formula which says for every input there
exists an output
such that if certain precondition
[Music]
is satisfied of the input if the input
is of the
right format let's say then some desired
post condition
which is a relation between the input
and the output holds so that's that's
a generic way of describing any
algorithmic problem understood as as
transforming inputs to
two outputs now if you manage to
deductively
prove realizability this realizability
formula of this function described by
by the relation between inputs and
outputs
then you may hope to extract the program
from that realizability proof
and you know there are people in proof
theory who who quite seriously
uh try to do things like that but this
is not what
what we are going to focus on we are
going to focus instead on
reactive synthesis in
reactive synthesis rather than focusing
on
data transformation in particular
transforming
infinite input domains into outputs
we focus instead on control and
on finite input
and output sets however
to make things um somewhat interesting
uh we consider but also applicable we
consider
a scenario in which the programs that we
would like to synthesize
are engaged uh in an ongoing interaction
with uh with the environment and that
interaction can take
arbitrary uh duration
and in fact uh we are going to model
that by
an infinite interaction uh
between the program
the controller and the environment
in such ongoing interactions and also
given
the focus on control rather than on data
transformation
what is quite natural is to
specify correctness of such systems
in terms of ordering of events that take
place in such interactions so in other
words
the correctness properties typically
would take a form of
so-called temporal properties now there
are many examples in which this
methodology
has been and is being successfully
applied
notably temples is synthesis of hardware
circuits which is definitely a
big success story of this approach but
also things like device drivers
robotic controllers and many many other
contexts now what is common to those
is that they tend to be the reactive
layer
of so-called cyber physical systems um
about which you can learn in ufos
tutorial and i trust that ufo will
mention reactive synthesis and uh show
examples of the uses of reactive
synthesis uh
in not only in theory but also in
practice
the model that
has been very influential in this area
and perhaps
the first formalization of
this idea of synthesis temporal
synthesis
is due to church so church alonzo church
back in 1950s
has posed a challenge
where he considered uh the model
in which um a controller or
as he called it a circuit a finite
device
is involved in interaction with the
environment
in a very simple manner namely
in discrete at discrete time points it
keeps
receiving inputs that come from
some finite set i the inputs are
provided at the screen time points by
the environment
and the environment uh continues
providing those inputs
forever so we can view the inputs as an
infinite sequence of elements of that
finite
set input set i now at every step
the program received such an input
and is required to produce an
output which again is an element
in a finite set o of outputs
church has formulated the following
question
assume that we are given a description
of the desired relationships between
the infinite sequence of the inputs
and the infinite sequence of the outputs
given in some logical formalism say
is there an algorithm that can
answer whether such a specification is
realizable
in the sense that there is a finite
program
let's call it p which for
every input sequence infinite input
sequence
is capable to
keep producing outputs
that are based only on
the information received so far
so let's denote by p of alpha the
sequence infinite sequence of outputs
produced in this matter
given an infinite sequence of inputs
alpha
that satisfy this specification
it was mcnauton in mid-1960s who has
observed
that church's synthesis problem
can be seen as solving a game
on a very simple graph
a game in which the environment
has a finite number of states
from which the environment chooses
the input letters and in turn
the controller has a finite number of
states
and from each of those states the
controller
chooses output letters so in other words
we have this bipartite game
or a game with bipartite on a bipartite
graph
in which the positions of the
environment
are the letters of the output but
crucially the environment picks the
input letters and positions of the
controller
are the letters the input letters
and from each of those uh the controller
picks
the output letters so this is this uh
very simple game graph uh with finite
number of positions
and the winning condition is provided by
the specification
so it's a it's a relation on
infinite sequences or it's a sequence of
vertices there
it's a set of sequences uh of vertices
in this very simple
game so the controller wins
an infinite sequence which is determined
uniquely by
the choices of the controller and the
environment
specified by these infinite input and
output sequences
if and only if the property
holds now what are the desired
uh strategies in such games that would
correspond to
these finite programs um in church's
synthesis problem well they are a very
simple form of
transducers or input output automata
that on any uh input letter
produced a single output letter that's
how
um charges problem is is formulated and
for that formulation this very basic
model of a synchronous transducer is
just the right
machine model and the reactive synthesis
then boils down to
finding a transducer which is a winning
strategy
for controller in this game with a very
simple game graph
but with possibly complex
winning condition
a solution of a church's problem
at least for specifications given
in monadic second order logic on
infinite words has been provided by
bishi and land web
and soon after that using slightly
different techniques
based on tree automata by rabin
so the result of bishi and land weber
is that realizability
for specifications and magnetic
second-order logic on
infinite words is decidable
and what is uh also quite remarkable
is that if a specification is realizable
then they have proved
that then uh a finite implementation
exists so there is a finite
state device which
realizes realizes their specification
so so that is very satisfactory answer
to
to church's question and it turns out
that
the key underlying result here
is finite memory determinacy
of uh omega regular games or games
in which the winning sets are omega
regular
because uh by the results that mikoy has
discussed in uh in his tutorial on on
logic
uh we all know that
um the
properties that are that can be
expressed using monolithic second order
logic
on words are exactly those that are
recognized by uh non-deterministic bhu
automata
uh that is the irregular properties
so how did bishi and lanweber
solve a church's synthesis problem well
they used what we could call nowadays
the logic automata games method
how does it look like so we start with
the specification formula
phi and let's say it is given in monadic
second order logic
on words so it's a temporal property
then by the results of beefy from early
60s
this can be translated if effectively
into
a non-deterministic bisho automaton
that recognizes exactly all those words
that are models of the original formula
then and crucially using uh mcnaughton's
determinization construction we can
produce an equivalent deterministic
parity automaton it is perhaps
worth noting that mcnaughton's
determinization construction didn't
actually produce
a parity automaton instead it gave
a malar automaton or an automaton a
deterministic automaton on
infinite words with the so-called malar
acceptance conditions
but thanks to advances since uh 1960s
we now know we have we know techniques
which allow to translate
from malar conditions uh
or rabine conditions that were proposed
by
rabin uh later on into party conditions
and somehow we relegate this
one particular source of complexity to
automata theory
and when solving games we focus on on
parity conditions
but why did we need to determinize the
automaton
and what is actually the parity game
over here
[Music]
let me discuss the need for
determinization in a minute
but for now let's let's actually
describe the parity game
so note that the original gate steward
game proposed by mac naughton
had a very simple arena it was just a
bipartite graph with positions that
corresponded to
inputs input letters and
output letters now the game we are going
to consider
is going to have more complex state
space or
a set of positions but a simpler
winning condition which is just going to
be a parity condition
so the positions are going to be pairs a
letter
and a state of the automaton and in a
way the role of the automaton is going
to
uh be to listen to what the players
decide
which letters they pick in every round
of the game
and adjust the state of the
deterministic automaton accordingly
because this deterministic automaton is
over the alphabet which is pairs of
input and output letters
and the parity it will be a parity game
because the winning condition will be a
parody condition that is simply
inherited
from the acceptance condition of
the automaton so
do we actually need deterministic
automata
so what if we instead of constructing
the product
game of the original gail stewart game
and a deterministic automaton what if we
constructed a game which is analogously
a product of the original
gate steward game uh arena and um
a non-deterministic bc automaton
well one problem here would be that
a non-deterministic automaton may have
multiple transitions
so there would be some sort of
choice here which will have to be
resolved preferably by one of the two
players
and actually makes quite good sense for
the controller
to take those choices so for the
controller
to decide which transitions
of the automaton that verifies the
specification
to pick because the automaton is
interested in finding
an accepting run and hence satisfying
the specification
however that is problematic
if the automaton is an arbitrary
non-deterministic automaton because
non-deterministic automata
are not necessarily causal
or using more modern terminology
history deterministic
in the sense that an automaton
may be unable and an arbitrary
non-deterministic automaton
may be unable to use the same
transitions
to accept two words that
share a common prefix
and non-deterministic automaton in other
words may need to know the future
so to say in order to pick a transition
at any
position in the world secondly
what we could do instead would be to
rather than using
deterministic parity automata we could
consider using deterministic
bihi automata however
they are less expressive than
non-deterministic behavior automata and
hence
we need parity conditions which uh
uh which are sufficient because there is
a determinization from non-domestic bc
to
uh deterministic parity uh we are going
to
to take a look at some alternatives to
using the deterministic parity automata
but let's first take a look at the
complexity
of the bhi and land weber
solution so for specifications in
monadic second order logical words
uh unfortunately this approach like for
satisfiability uh results
often results or may result in
non-elementary blow up
of the size of the automaton that's
because
translation of mso
formulas into automata may involve
complementations
linear number of complementations and
every complementation may result in
exponential blow up
in fact stockmayer has rigorously
established
that satisfiability and hence also
realizability for
mso onwards is in fact non-elementary so
it cannot be bounded by any
tower of exponentials of bounded
of bounded height
now the there is also
a blow up and uh price to pay for
determinization
the original mcnauton's construction was
doubly exponential so there was a doubly
exponential increase in the number of
states from the original
non-deterministic automaton to a
deterministic
matter in mcnaughton's case condition
which seems uh modest compared to the
non-elementary blow up
in a translation from logic to automata
but it's still
quite painful now
safra in 1980s has for the first time
come up with
an optimal uh complementation sorry
determinization construction
uh which involved only singly
exponential blow up and that was very
influential result because it
uh it has uh spurred a lot of feather
work
um in applications of
automata theoretic methods in logic and
in particular
in uh applications to logics other than
the monadic second order logic so one
very influential
example was uh temporal logic so it was
in late 1970s who proposed to use
linear temporal logic for specification
and and verification and
uh soon after safra's determinization
construction
nuelle and rosner have established that
if we take specifications in linear
temporal logic
then the reactive synthesis problem is
in fact
solvable in doubly exponential time
and later on rosner has established that
this is indeed
to ex time complete
so here's a picture of this automat
logic automata
games method for for the synthesis
problem the picture is the same as we've
discussed
before but here we also uh
take a look at what cost
what computational complex what
computational cost is involved
in uh starting from monadic second order
logic
specifications it's already known
elementary in the first step
from the for for the logic to automata
translation
for ltl this the the blow-ups are modest
the first
translation from formulas to automatize
only singly exponential
and then because the um determinization
construction of sapphire is again
exponential
the number of states uh goes to
doubly exponential after determinization
uh
however the number of priorities is only
singly exponential
uh so uh in the in the end what we get
is a deterministic parity
uh automaton and then a parity game of w
exponential size
so uh although translations
from logic to automata and then
determinization constructions are very
critical
obviously when you when they incur a
doubly exponential blow up
uh in order for this this to be
practical you better have
uh uh very good and algorithm engineer
algorithms engineering
uh techniques to uh make sure that
these blow-ups these theoretical
blow-ups do not hurt too much in
practice
but it is also quite important to be
able to solve party games
efficiently because these parity games
can be quite large
and until quite recently all
algorithms for solving parity games were
unfortunately exponential
in the number of priorities that's a
critical parameter that we have
discussed
earlier for example in the context of
nested fixed points
now a truly groundbreaking result just a
few years ago
was obtained by kaluda jain who signed
off lee and
stefan who have managed to obtain the
first
fixed parameter tractable algorithm
for solving parity games when the
parameter is the number of priorities
so that that's a major advance in fact
their algorithm works in a
quasi-polynomial
time in general
and the complexity is in fact
exponential only in the
logarithm of the number of priorities so
that's a major advance from
a linear number uh lin something
linear in the number of priorities in
the exponent
and moreover it is in polynomial time if
the number of priorities is only
logarithmic in the number of
positions in the game now note that that
here indeed this is the case uh
in the parity games that are obtained
from uh ltl synthesis
uh so one could argue that uh this
really uh
um solves the problem of applications of
parity games
um to
ltl reactive synthesis however i
i believe that it's still interesting to
find better algorithms and in particular
algorithms that are good not only in
theory but but also in practice
so finally let us come back to the
question of
whether we can avoid determinization
in this solution bc land webber solution
of of church's synthesis problem
and as i have already hinted
there could be a way to to in fact use
non-deterministic automata
and it was hensinger and petermann who
have come up with a
formal concept of a so-called what they
called good for games nondeterministic
automata
a concept that was later rediscovered
and
and called uh somewhat more generally a
history deterministic automata by thomas
and that can be um
described in the following way we would
say that an automaton
on words a is good for games or history
deterministic
if and here is a game theoretic
characterization again if it is the case
that if we consider a game in which
we have two players in automaton and
spoiler and the automaton tries to
produce
uh accepting runs and a spoiler
has the power to pick words
so spoiler in every rounds of the game
so to say the spoiler picks
letters input letters and then the
automaton
needs to pick uh valid transitions
uh given the current state of the
automaton and the letter that was
that has just been picked by the spotter
so
and then we say that
uh the automaton wins in an infinite
play of such a game or finite if if
we consider finite automaton because
this
this uh definition could indeed be
applied to to automaton finite words as
well
if it is the case that
the resulting run that is produced not
that
together spoiler and automaton produce
runs because spoiler picks letters and
automaton picks transitions
so an automaton the automaton player
wins
such a pair word and
run if it is the case that
um the word being in the language
implies that the
run picked is accepting so in other
words
an automaton wins in this game if they
can
choose transitions in a history
deterministic way
based only on the letters that have been
read so far now this definition is
exactly what is needed
um to make that product construction
with a nondeterministic automaton
correct so if that non-deterministic
automaton happens to be
good for games then the resulting game
in which
the controller is also given the
responsibility to pick the transitions
it is equivalent to the gail stewart
game
in which the winning condition is
provided
as the language recognized by the
automaton
now the properties constructions
of these good for games automata
and their uses in synthesis uh are a
topic of ongoing
current research and there are even a
few experts
on this in the theoretical foundations
of computer systems program at simon's